The Lady. Providing nutrition for our young babies, they are one of the few members
Which do not develop entirely at birth, and of course a great obsession with Western culture
But there is still a lot that has not been discussed about the 'or was considered taboo
What does science say about the fast?
Forget about wine and wine. What about blood to milk? Proteins, sugars and fats are withdrawn
From the blood supply of hope to making milk, this is what made mammals
Very successful. Unlike birds or reptiles that rely on their parents to be brought
Her food from the outside like insects, mammals, from the word mammal, gets nutrients
At an early age of secretion of breast milk
Breastfeeding comes in all shapes and sizes, although there is a positive correlation between breast size
Genes also play an important role in the size of the body. In 50% of cases it is
One breast is bigger than the other, often it is the left breast. It is known as an asymmetry of the breasts
Asymmetry is normal, although scientists are not entirely clear about the cause, except I am there a potential contribution
For changes in hormones that occur in adulthood
Variety varies from week to week! Yes, production of estrogen and progesterone during
PMS works to change the size of the breast
All men and women have nipples and mammary glands, but often develop only in women
At puberty. This characteristic characterizes humans, and other mammalian mammals only swell
When nurturing and feeding their young. A ring of skin dyed and surrounded by the nipple "halo"
And are covered with small protozoa called Montgomery glands. When the milk is released, the glands produce
The secretions keep the nipple lubricated, and may release compounds that make
Looks delicious to the baby
The nipple consists not only of one hole, but of a large number of small holes that you can not see
With the naked eye. After placing the baby, the nipple receptors are determined when the baby starts
In breast feeding, you send messages to the mother's brain, triggering oxytocin release and persistence
Production of prolactin. Oxytocin acts to constrict the cells lining the mammary glands
Also known as the incubation hormone, it strengthens the bond between the mother
And the child. Proactin is necessary for milk production. This hormonal process is complete
Can be launched after hearing baby crying! Even if it is your child
Children love to be loved, as well as people who love them too. One research found that people spent more time in observation
Big bites with a certain proportion of your hips and width - this is likely to explain why
Breast enlargement surgeries are the most common forms of plastic surgery, with 300,000 operations
It was conducted in 2014 in America alone. However the same research shows that people
They prefer to be eaten in all shapes and sizes, and medium-sized lentils are classified
Statistically it is the most attractive. Hunters not only create pleasure for others, but also create them
For the same person. Studies have shown that stimulating nipples enhances sexual arousal at 82%
Of women and 52% of men. Interestingly, the magnetic resonance imaging scan was a brain response
For self-stimulation of the clitoris and vagina, and found that these areas are triggered when women
By stimulating the nipples
Although the source of both nutrient and pleasure is a source of sustenance, it remains a non-vulnerable region
Breast cancer is one of the most common types of cancer in North America. Cells that are divided
They are often at greater risk of mutations than undifferentiated cells
They change and grow during our life cycle, these cells are constantly divided. Hormone
Estrogen also stimulates the division of breast cells, and there are some environmental chemicals present
In pesticides, industrial products and even foods that mimic estrogen and which can affect
Cell growth, increasing the risk of breast cancer. Research reveals other risk factors
For breast cancer such as breast density, age at first pregnancy and genetic predisposition
For breast cancer genes such as BRCA1 and BRCA2. This scientific knowledge can help increase
protection
Although the stamina is not immune, it is unbelievably wonderful, regardless of sizes and shapes but it is
A necessary aspect to the preservation of human life, and our definition as one species. Thank you
Want to know more about the bulls? Watch the latest video "AsapTHOUGHT video" where we disassemble
About Why Women Give Out. Click on the screen or use the link in the description
And subscribe to more weekly science videos